Angelina Jolie gets candid about her
marriage to Brad Pitt now she admits
there was trouble years before they
decided to divorce and in a new podcast
Angelina says she hoped sharing the
screen in 2015 by the sea would help
bring them closer together it should
have been good for us to be honest I
wanted to work with him because we had
met working together we worked together
well and I wanted us to do some serious
work together I thought that it could be
a good way for us to communicate but
there was a heaviness probably during
that situation that carried on and it
wasn't because of the film it may not
have been a good idea that's what
Angelina says now about working on the
super depressing film as a honeymoon
project maybe it didn't solve certain
things but we did communicate something
that maybe needed to be communicated to
each other we would have also liked to
have known was at Brad's drinking too
much for their control issues but The
Hollywood Reporter did get some insight
on Angie's next move what do you think
these next few years
poultry teenagers mom life and a return
to doing kicked butt films I tend to do
them when I need to feel strong I'm
looking for one now in fact because of
this time in my life I feel like I I
need to pick some up I do
[Music]